ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález van ya 14
días y sigue contando desde el inicio de
la invasión de rusia a ucrania ya los
ojos del mundo están concentrados en lo
que sucede en este país en el este de
europa pero también están concentrados
en esos corredores humanitarios que van
a permitir la salida de miles de civiles
que han quedado bajo el fuego cruzado y
sobre todo están concentradas las
miradas en ese veto que recibió la
compra de petróleo ruso por parte de
eeuu y por supuesto el éxodo masivo de
personas desde territorio ucraniano
hacia los países vecinos como polonia
moldavia rumanía hungría y eslovaquia
veamos cómo está la situación hasta el
día de hoy vamos a ver cómo está el
avance de las tropas rusas han
conseguido capturar ya buena parte del
este del país del este de ucrania la ya
conocida región del donbass pues está
bajo su control la costa ucraniana en el
mar de azov ya está en posesión rusa lo
mismo que buena parte del sur de ucrania
la península de crimea está bajo control
ruso desde el 2014 aunque no recibe
reconocimiento internacional
también controlan la franja desde la
frontera hasta la ciudad de hardcore que
estaba bajo asedio desde hace varios
días y también la ciudad de schumi donde
hubo una evacuación de civiles a través
de un corredor humanitario que fue
habilitado sólo faltaría entonces una
pequeña franja entre jarkko y la región
del donbass para que rusia controle por
completo la frontera común con ucrania
recientemente también ha habido avances
en medio de fuertes enfrentamientos
entre las tropas rusas y ucranianas en
dirección a la ciudad de kiev partiendo
desde el norte y desde el este del país
allí buena parte de las tropas rusas han
venido avanzando muchas de ellas desde
el norte desde la frontera común con
belarús que no está sino a unos 130
kilómetros de distancia de la capital
pero hay una gran resistencia por parte
de los ucranianos por por eso del avance
y la conquista de la capital digámoslo
así no ha sido tan rápido también podría
ser parte de la estrategia de los rusos
hacer una aproximación a la capital un
poco más lenta
rusia y ucrania son importantes
exportadores de granos y la guerra está
interrumpiendo el flujo habitual de la
distribución a nivel mundial de estos
granos por lo que los precios en estos
alimentos clave están aumentando veamos
cómo están las cosas
los efectos de la guerra se hacen notar
esto es nacido en irak
los ciudadanos iraquíes deben recibir
una parte del petróleo lo exigimos desde
ahora y hasta que se cumplan nuestras
demandas el alza en los precios de los
combustibles preocupa en todo el mundo y
en bagdad la capital iraquí también el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
donde el costo del aceite casi se
cuatriplicó
pueden creer que tengo que pagar 15
dólares por una lata de aceite como lo
voy a hacer también hay gastos en la
casa en la escuela cómo vamos a vivir
ucrania prohibió la exportación de trigo
avena y otros alimentos básicos y a 2400
kilómetros está teniendo impacto en el
mayor importador de trigo del mundo
egipto depende del grano ucraniano
aunque el gobierno asegura tener
reservas para todo 2022 al otro lado del
mediterráneo en túnez la preocupación es
mayor y caixa jet presidente tunecino
mandó una advertencia en plena escasez
quiero que sea una guerra implacable
contra los especuladores criminales pero
la crisis también llega hasta los países
occidentales en alemania los precios del
diésel están en niveles récord mientras
hay una escasez de entre 60 y 80 mil
conductores
la guerra de ucrania ha provocado que
los precios del diésel se disparen de
manera exorbitante actualmente tenemos
entre 50 y 60 centavos por litro de
costos adicionales en este segmento
lamentablemente tenemos que trasladar
este aumento de costos a nuestros
clientes
los impactos en las exportaciones clave
desde ucrania y rusia también afectan al
transporte en un aumento del precio que
acabará afectando a todos los productos
transportados
así las cosas hoy destacan entonces
cuatro temas el primero ya lo veíamos el
avance de las tropas rusas el segundo
los corredores humanitarios el tercero
estas casas de granos a nivel mundial
que les estábamos mostrando y sumó un
cuarto tema ya es el tema energético
porque también fue destacado el día de
hoy esas declaraciones del alto
representante de la unión europea para
la política exterior quien habló del
temor que hay en bloque comunitario ante
la posible suspensión del suministro de
gas como represalia por parte de rusia
ante las sanciones y todos estos vetos
que le está imponiendo la comunidad
internacional él pidió a los europeos
simplemente ahorrar gas y apagar las
calefacciones estas fueron sus palabras
con una nueva directiva que pretende
recortar de aquí fin de año en dos
terceras partes nuestra dependencia del
gas ruso objetivo difícil pero
realizable si realmente nos aplicamos a
ello y eso requieren medidas
macroeconómicas medidas técnicas y
también
también pide que los ciudadanos europeos
bajen la calefacción de sus casas
también pide que todo el mundo haga un
esfuerzo individual en recortar el
consumo de gas igual que recortamos el
consumo de agua cuando hay sequía e
igual cuando nos ponemos una máscara
para combatir el virus lo que hemos
hecho contra el quabit 19 lo hemos de
hacer a favor de ucrania
la pregunta es si los ciudadanos de la
unión europea están dispuestos a hacer
estos recortes y a suspender el uso de
las calefacciones el invierno todavía no
ha terminado hay en europa cómo
repercute el método de las exportaciones
del petróleo ruso a eeuu que podemos
analizar de esos nuevos acercamientos de
washington con caracas con miras a que
venezuela supla esa demanda de petróleo
ruso cómo está la situación humanitaria
en ucrania europa puede seguir haciendo
frente al alto flujo de personas que
están llegando desde este país moldavia
por ejemplo ya comenzaron a levantar las
manos porque su capacidad económica está
bajo presión con la llegada de personas
procedentes de ucrania la actualidad de
lo que está sucediendo la guerra en este
país en el este del continente europeo
después de la invasión de rusia el golpe
a la economía mundial lo vamos a
analizar hoy en el debate de france 24 y
para conversar sobre este tema está con
nosotros olga cerrado ella es vocera de
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
está en ciudad de panamá y desde ciudad
de mexico se conecta también a esta
conversación marcela chapa garza ya es
directora de la escuela de relaciones
internacionales universidad anáhuac
querétaro les recuerdo que ustedes
también son parte de esta conversación
participen en el debate con los
comentarios y las preguntas que deseen
hacer las pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas sabemos de la importancia
que genera a nivel internacional
lo que está sucediendo en ucrania lo
vemos a través de las transmisiones que
hemos hecho recientemente que tiene un
alto flujo de sintonía por parte de
ustedes desde diferentes puntos de
américa latina' coméntenos desde donde
se está viendo usted la señal de france
24 comienzos entonces el debate
preguntándole a mi invitada en ciudad de
panamá olga preguntándole primero por la
parte humanitaria en los esfuerzos que
se están haciendo para recibir a los
miles de refugiados ya poco más de dos
millones han llegado a diferentes países
europeos
cuanto más puede resistir a europa este
alto flujo porque llevamos solamente 14
días de
conflicto allí en ucrania y ya más de 2
millones de personas se han dejado el
país
bueno si es ni dos semanas y ya son más
de dos millones de personas que han
dejado el país principalmente llegando a
cinco países vecinos a polonia
eslovaquia hungría moldavia
sabemos que es una situación muy
compleja para los países vecinos pero
algo que tenemos que destacar es la gran
solidaridad con la que están recibiendo
no solamente los países sino también los
ciudadanos los voluntarios que se han
acercado desde el primer día al afronta
la frontera con ucrania las fronteras
con ucrania para recibir a esas personas
que están saliendo pero la pregunta que
que nos lanza es es muy válida no hasta
cuando esta solidaridad bueno esperemos
que esta solidaridad continúe pero a
medida que las cifras van aumentando y
también teniendo en cuenta que la
situación empeora y las necesidades de
las personas que están saliendo en este
momento también se incrementan es más
importante que nunca que la solidaridad
no solamente de los países vecinos sino
de todos los países de la unión europea
y más adelante también de todos los
países del mundo pues se vea
incrementada no sólo el nivel de fondos
pero también en apoyo a estos países
sobre todo que llevamos solamente 14
días ya superamos los 2 millones de
personas
saliendo desde ucrania y la onu estima
que sea entre 4 y 5 millones estaríamos
ya por la mitad y tampoco se sabe cuánto
va a durar este conflicto y si las
partes van a negociar y esto terminará
pronto o no pasó preguntarle ahora a
marcela en ciudad de méxico vamos a
estar saltando del tema humanitario al
tema de la actualidad y lo que viene
sucediendo hay en ucrania a lo largo de
la jornada lo destacaba a marcela en el
tema económico en las repercusiones que
puede tener este veto a nivel
internacional la compra del petróleo
ruso por parte de eeuu esto ya empieza a
repercutir en las finanzas a nivel
mundial en las bolsas y en la venta de
petróleo y se puede generar entonces un
efecto bola de nieve estamos a puertas
de una nueva crisis económica que piensa
usted
seguramente económica y es la más
importante y bloques de alimentaria no
esté acá 20 estamos hablando del
petróleo en entrenos muy concretos no
pero seguramente vamos a tener una alza
de precios en muchos aspectos vamos a
necesitar también pues ya que ya
acabamos de ver también las
implicaciones políticas de esta no
estados unidos buscando venezuela al
régimen de maduro cuando de alguna
manera esto también va a cambiar la
balanza de cara a cómo se estaban
manejando las relaciones de esos países
el tema de la oposición venezolana
también se va a ver afectado por por por
púrpura este real politik y por puro
tema este pues y estratégico energético
no entonces bueno él
a esto también se le suma el día de hoy
el reino unido también esté proponiendo
un plan de desfase de
utilización del petróleo ruso durante
todo este año
y bueno pues de alguna manera si vamos
de por sí ya estábamos en momentos de
muy alta inflación en eeuu está viviendo
uno de sus momentos de inflación más
altos en varias décadas y justamente el
tema del alza de precios por todo lo que
pasó en los últimos dos años por
el coronavirus y entonces justamente
estamos viendo que en la cima de todo
esto lo que está pasando en estos
momentos con la disrupción de ciertas
cadenas de suministro sobre todo
energética pues lo vamos a ver que que
seguramente afecta marcela continuó con
ustedes ya le doy la palabra a olga
quiero preguntarle qué estamos 14 días
desde el inicio de esta invasión de las
tropas rusas al territorio ucraniano qué
tanta presión hay en este momento sobre
el presidente vladimir putin con estas
sanciones que ha recibido su país el
círculo cercano de los poderosos
económicamente hablando allí en este
país que tanta presiones sobre el
kremlin en este momento
ha sido una de las grandes estrategias
de sobretodo entes privados y algunos
países atacan a los oligarcas y atacar
este el sector financiero por ahora una
de las estrategias que han encontrado ha
sido
optar por la script o maneras hemos
visto una alza muy grande en las criptas
monedas en los últimos días por
individuos y privados rusos
el tema conduce es que es muy complejo
tener información interna sabemos que
justamente uno de los de los
instrumentos de guerra que está
utilizando armas en estos momentos es el
tema de la guerra cibernética
informática lo que se dice lo que se
publica lo que sale lo que no
seguramente si hay enojo de los
oligarcas seguramente si hay presión
pero creo que estamos en un momento de
que el conflicto se escalo
a tal grado que la presión interna no
vaya a ser lo más determinante
seguramente si va a ser uno de los
tantos factores no para hay que tener en
cuenta muchos otros hay que tener en la
venta la resistencia este militar
etcétera regreso a olga en ciudad de
panamá para retomar el tema humanitario
él lo destacaba también al inicio del
programa olga los corredores
humanitarios no ha sido un punto fácil
de negociar entre ucranianos y rusos en
estas rondas de negociación que han
tenido en los últimos días pero para la
evacuación de la ciudad de simios um y
si hubo un corredor habilitado y por
allí pudieron salir miles de personas
esto denota que posiblemente las fuerzas
rusas iban a tomar ya la ciudad o por lo
menos iba a haber ataques a gran escala
como se articulan estos corredores
humanitarios y organismos
internacionales como el que usted
representa qué papel juegan ahí o cómo
se articula esto dentro de esas mesas de
diálogo entre las dos partes que están
enfrentadas
bueno antes estábamos hablando de
las cifras no de esos dos millones esos
dos millones son personas que han salido
de ucrania pero no nos podemos olvidar
de los miles cientos de miles millones
de personas que continúan dentro de
ucrania y que se encuentran en una
situación de terror de miedo por su vida
por la de sus familiares y de no saber
dónde van
a continuar a estar mañana como les va a
afectar el conflicto que estamos viendo
es importante es importante que esos
pasos seguros se faciliten y que
permitan ambas cosas no solamente a las
personas que quieran salir de sus
ciudades de sus hogares en busca de
seguridad hacia otras partes del país o
hacia fuera del país que sea posible
pero también que la ayuda humanitaria
que desde acnur o de otras
organizaciones humanitarias tenemos pre
posicionada podamos entrar a aquellas
zonas para entregarla a aquellas
personas que deciden quedarse donde
están o aquellas personas que necesitan
esa ayuda de emergencia de insumos
sanitarios comida e insumos de higiene
mantas hay que entender que estamos en
una época de invierno nuevo cráneo con
temperaturas heridas entonces es
importante que se que se respeten esos
espacios para que podamos tener ese
acceso a los ciudadanos a los civiles
que lo necesitan olga al día de hoy que
tanto margen de acción han tenido
ustedes en este conflicto que tanto han
podido entrar a dar asistencia
humanitaria a ayudar ahora en este
conflicto
nosotros tenemos equipos que ya estaban
antes de que hace dos semanas ya llevan
tiempo basados dentro del país y que al
igual que el resto de la población han
tenido que pasar días noches enteras en
búnkers muchos de ellos también por
temor a sus familias que se encuentran
con temor a lo que podría pasar a sus
familias que se encuentran en otras
zonas del país estamos dentro pero es
verdad que no hemos podido llegar a
todos los sitios en los que creemos que
necesitamos debido a la seguridad pero
estamos llegando a esas zonas en el país
y pre posicionados en esas zonas del
país en las que sí que tenemos acceso y
podemos estar entregando pues como
comentaba no colchones alimentos mantas
a las personas que lo necesitan eso
dentro del país y además los en todas
las fronteras estamos apoyando a las
autoridades de los países vecinos y
bueno pero posicionando como comentaba
estos insumos humanitarios y también
empezando programas por ejemplo de
dinero en efectivo que es muy necesario
en este momento para que las personas
puedan cubrir sus necesidades básicas
pero también apoyo psicológico porque
aunque las personas que cruzan la
frontera tienen seguridad en trauma y la
violencia por la que han pasado pues
perduran y ese apoyo es muy necesario
retomó el tema político con marcela
ansiedad de méxico marcela e interesante
analizar esa estrategia o no ya usted me
dirá cuál es su opinión al respecto que
ha tenido eeuu en el manejo de esta
situación del abastecimiento de petróleo
por parte de rusia que es alrededor del
3 por ciento del petróleo que consume
eeuu y que ahora que pone sus ojos en
venezuela nicolás maduro tratando de
hacer acercamientos washington caracas
para que venezuela tal vez pueda
suministrar ese porcentaje de petróleo
como entiendo usted esta estrategia
estamos en política hablando pero
también estamos en medio de un conflicto
sí y seguramente de alguna manera y en
algunos encabezados que la
elección del real politik no a final de
cuentas e inclusive cuando cuando hay
ciertos ideales y hay ciertos valores
por los que alguna nación empuja o busca
a la hora de la hora en realidad también
tiene muchísimo peso el tema este pues
en este momento muy concretamente el
tema energético y el suministro la
dependencia que tenemos de
pues de este tipo de
insumos para que la vida cotidiana
funcione no entonces eso es una presión
muchísimo mayor
a cualquier
digamos estrategia de política exterior
y que de alguna manera pues seguramente
esté hay ciertos márgenes no pero pero
seguramente encontramos está este
acercamiento por una necesidad
imprescindible
y aparte muy pronto no solo tenemos aquí
en la puerta de la esquina no es una
cosa que estamos pensando para las
próximas décadas como se ha hecho década
la transición energética por el medio
ambiente no no aquí es mañana hoy mismo
marcela pero
eeuu está aprovechándose de esta
situación para mejorar sus indicadores
económicos la presencia y también la
aprobación del presidente joe biden fue
muy criticado con el retiro de las
tropas de afganistán y ahora lo vemos
apoyando ciegamente a ucrania a través
de la otan y a través de sus aliados
europeos que tanto ha beneficiado a eeuu
esta incursión en ucrania de las tropas
rusas que ellos han manejado a través de
como lo digo en la alianza internacional
no han incursionado militarmente allí
pero tienen las tropas desplegadas en
los países vecinos y con este movimiento
inesperado con caracas
son muchos aspectos no yo creo que lo
primero que hay que considerar es que si
definitivamente eeuu pues en el tema de
política exterior había tenido pues este
desacierto de afganistán que por otra
parte es mucho creo que uno de los
grandes peligros a los que eeuu y las
otras potencias europeas no se podían
permitir de alguna manera era
de este tema de que el la incursión
hacia ucrania fuera tan rápida y tan
burda porque sabemos que de alguna
manera las grandes potencias habían
estado siempre involucradas en los
conflictos de estos últimos años pero
mucho menos directamente acepción de
eeuu no esté pero con las guerras proxy
apoyando grupos apoyando separatistas
como justamente en el caso este del este
de ucrania no sea como que pero el hecho
de que hubiera habido una invasión tan
tan directa de parte de una grande
potencia de alguna manera estaba
marcando un porqué puedo
y eso tiene un costo muy alto en la
política internacional y esta es una de
las cosas que las grandes potencias
sobre todo occidentales están poniendo
tanta energía en las sanciones para que
eso no suceda no en cierta forma se
repitió un poco el guión de la segunda
guerra mundial que eeuu despegó como
potencia a nivel económico después de de
la destrucción de europa la necesidad
económica del continente europeo por
recibir ayuda de eeuu puso en marcha
toda una maquinaria militar que hizo
despegar la la industria en eeuu puede
ser un capítulo similar para aprovechar
y despegar también la industria en este
momento en eeuu retomó la comunicación
con olga en ciudad de panamá
lo mencionaba también al inicio del
programa en la introducción y es
importante hablarlo es la capacidad olga
que tienen los países vecinos para
atender toda esta crisis humanitaria que
se está presentando polonia tiene mucha
ayuda de la unión europea ha tenido
ayuda de los países vecinos eslovaquia
hungría también pero bolt está bien no
es un país de la unión europea y es un
país con muchos problemas económicos es
uno de los países más pobres
en europeo junto con albania y está
haciendo frente a esta crisis
humanitaria que ya está empezando a
desbordar sus capacidades quien puede
ayudar a moldavia quien puede darle una
ayuda ya alzó las manos y dijo no puedo
bruselas ayúdenme washington ayúdeme
porque no puedo hacer frente
económicamente a esta situación y cada
vez son más personas que optan por los
pasos a través de moldavia
bueno pues así hemos visto que que la
solidaridad que han mostrado los países
vecinos todos incluido moldavia ha sido
espectaculares sin precedentes en los
últimos días pero no podemos
acostumbrarnos a esa solidaridad a
medida que las cifras aumentan también
la presión aumenta además vimos que
muchas de las personas que han estado
saliendo pues en estos primeros días
eran personas que podían tener
conexiones familiares que podían tener
suficiente dinero para buscar soluciones
por ellos mismos entonces después de la
ayuda inmediata de emergencia podían
buscar una solución y continuar por sus
propios medios eso vamos a ver qué va a
cambiar en los próximos días en las
próximas semanas veremos que llegan en
personas con menos recursos o personas
que han tardado más en salir pues porque
eran personas mayores personas con
discapacidad va a ser personas que van a
necesitar mucho más apoyo y por eso es
fundamental que no que no contemos
simplemente con esa solidaridad que
hemos visto hoy con una compañera que
está en la frontera los voluntarios
también están agotados después de estas
dos semanas recibiendo por ejemplo en el
caso de polonia hasta cien mil personas
al día no son cifras enormes entonces es
importante que la comunidad
internacional apoye a estos países a
seguir con las respuestas que han puesto
en marcha esa salida ordenada esa ayuda
de emergencia pero también a las
organizaciones humanitarias que pues se
lanzó un
pedido de fondos de más de 1.700
millones de dólares entre todo entre
todas las organizaciones humanitarias
para apoyar fuera y dentro de la
operación entonces ahora es cuando es
importante mostrar esa solidaridad
nosotros estamos en contacto con todas
las autoridades para apoyar a la gente
sea necesario y es fundamental ese apoyo
a todos los países oiga está contemplado
una segunda fase de esta crisis
humanitaria que puedo podemos decir que
puede ser estas personas
que se queden en ucrania porque ahora
están saliendo los que tienen capacidad
económica tienen familiares que les
ayudan a salir del país se tienen los
medios para poderlo hacer a través de
las fronteras que tiene ucrania pero que
hay de aquellos que no lo pueden hacer
que no tienen un pasaporte que no tienen
los recursos económicos y que se tienen
que quedar en el país está contemplada
esa segunda fase de crisis humanitaria
porque ellos se van a quedar allí no hay
alimentos no hay suministro de energía
seguimos con un invierno muy frío una
primavera que sigue siendo muy fría y
las fuerzas rusas avanzando
contemplaría como una segunda fase son
dos fases que están yendo en paralelo a
la vez que estamos apoyando a los países
fronterizos donde están llegando cientos
de miles de personas al día estamos
también apoyando dentro el reto ahora es
que no hay un acceso seguro a todas las
personas que lo necesitan pero así es o
sea cuando se produce un conflicto una
guerra las consecuencias durante años
iván como comentabas desde
de preparar la infraestructura que ha
podido ser dañada pero todos esos daños
psicológicos de trauma de vivir
experiencias que no se esperaban hace
tan sólo unos días
nadie no familias separadas entonces esa
en esa respuesta ya se está dando
estamos preparados para ella pero sí que
es verdad pues como comentaba es
importante asegurar ese paso y la
llegada de los insumos humanitarios a
quienes lo necesitan
marcela analicemos ahora
el lado ucraniano de esta historia de
los hechos recientes a lo largo de la
jornada de hoy el presidente selenski
presionando un poco a la unión europea
para acelerar ese trámite de
incorporación a la unión europea esto
también puede ser un poco una estrategia
aprovechando la situación que está
viviendo ucrania para acelerar ese
proceso porque claramente ucrania no
estaba en condiciones de entrar a la
unión europea tal y como estaba en
términos de economía de derechos de
modificaciones a su constitución y ya
empezó a medio mencionar por los lados
que tal vez ucrania podría olvidarse de
la otan ésta tal vez cambiando el
discurso está cediendo terreno entre los
rusos está viendo ya la presión de moscú
muy encima y siente que es momento de
ceder terreno
es seguramente todo lo anterior no esté
de alguna manera en la última ronda de
negociaciones rusia dejó muy claro qué
es lo que se quería no porque al
principio era un o sea que que siguen o
que están buscando que quieren los rusos
no y los rusos lo dejaban muy claro no
querían está que la neutralidad de
octano quedara inclusive impactada en
una nueva constitución
buscaban pues la la autonomía completa
el conocimiento la autonomía completa de
las autodenominadas repúblicas del este
y también el reconocimiento total de
crimea no como como la anexión rusa
entonces esto definitivamente parten
como un punto de negociación claro desde
donde el cual pues ya éste empiezan pues
este juego de negociación de decisiones
por una parte y otras para poder llegar
a un fin porque porque claro acá hay
estrategias militares y hay estrategias
de las sanciones económicas para el cine
vamos a tener que ir a un acuerdo si
queremos que esto se termine y parte de
eso pues seguramente si es este ceder en
el tema de que quedó clarísimo que para
rusia es un tema de seguridad nacional
fuerte y delicado atender a la otan en
sus fronteras no entonces si de alguna
manera eso es uno de los temas que hay
que negociar en
este proceso para llegar a unas cuatro a
un punto políticamente
que nos acerque más al final de esta
guerra pues por ahí está yendo no y qué
análisis puede hacer de los hechos
recientes en cuanto a la unión europea
le pregunto porque el tema energético
presiona muchos países por ejemplo como
alemania que depender mucho del gas ruso
ahora que va a empezar
o existe la posibilidad de que sea
cortada ese suministro procedente de
rusia hay países del continente que
dependen 100% caso macedonia del norte
de caso
serbia pero otros países de la unión
europea por lo menos han dicho no
despacio el tema energético es
preocupante y hablo del primer ministro
rutte de los países bajos que levantó la
mano también en la unión europea en
bruselas y dijo no esto hay que
manejarlo con calma despacio no podemos
sacar el suministro ruso así como así
tan rápido se siguen viendo divisiones
en la unión europea a la hora de tratar
los temas con rusia no hay una cohesión
y llevamos 14 días de conflicto
y siempre el tema de la política
exterior de la unión europea comunión
europea implica demasiados consensos con
muchos países con realidades muy
distintas que tienen intereses diversos
en distintos temas no entonces partimos
desde desde ese desde ese punto y
definitivamente dentro de la unión como
tal tenemos países con una dependencia
tremenda casi al 100% como por ejemplo
finlandia los países bálticos al gas
ruso y pues definitivamente los otros
mayores pues socios comerciales de cara
al gas son alemania italia y francia el
tema es que la unión europea al
apostarle a la carbonización de la
economía en los últimos años pues
evidentemente optó por el gas como una
de las opciones si las energías
renovables pero en un menor grado
el gas ahora de alguna manera en la
unión europea depende el 25 por ciento
de su suministro energético de gas no
entonces y rusia siendo uno de los
principales proveedores entonces este
tema de que de que poco a poco han ido
bajando su dependencia del carbono ha
hecho este en este pues dependientes de
de su proveedor que en este caso
infusión entonces definitivamente
otras países han optado los países han
optado por por las sanciones en otro
sentido en otro tipo de
bienes y servicios y los financieros y
si y otro tipo de cortes pero el gas es
muy delicado para todos y estamos apenas
viendo los efectos de éste de esta
amenaza de rusia de cortar el suministro
de gas a europa y también de los efectos
que pueda tener la decisión de eeuu de
no comprar más petróleo ruso me quedan
un par de minutos para finalizar el
programa olga quiero que hablemos de las
conclusiones lo que sucede en ucrania
cambia minuto a minuto es imposible
saber qué va a suceder pero en el tema
humanitario como ve usted las
situaciones de preocuparnos lo que pueda
venir para los próximos días que puede
usted ver hacia el futuro de esta
situación tal y como se está
desarrollando hasta ahora
bueno pues la situación humanitaria no
va a mejorar
entonces lo más importante si si podemos
hacer dos llamados el primero es a la
paz o sencilla si no hay violencia
la situación van poco a poco mejoraría
estabilizarse y el segundo es a esa
solidaridad no tiene que continuar
continuar por los países vecinos pero
también por los países europeos por el
resto del mundo y cada uno de nosotros
tenemos que poner pues nuestro nuestro
granito de arena y ser solidarios con
esos países y con los ucranianos no que
en este momento están pasando un momento
tan complicado y marcela su conclusión
que puede pasar en términos políticos en
términos económicos los efectos que
pueden tener las decisiones que han
tomado en la jornada de hoy yo creo que
los efectos más importantes que tenemos
que tener en mente van a ser la
seguridad alimentaria no sé muchos
países están cerrando sus fronteras a la
exportación de trigo y de otros granos y
de aceite precisamente por el miedo a
que de alguna manera entre rusia y
ucrania esté representada en el 30 por
ciento de las exportaciones en un día es
de trigo y el 80% del aceite de palma
entonces eso hace que los país en estos
momentos estén los precios del trigo
están por los cielos en estos momentos
los precios de los diferentes aceites y
de las otras commodities para
por ejemplo la soya el maíz y entonces
eso podemos esperar que escale muy
pronto y que vaya y vaya a causar
conflictos en los países sobre todo que
más dificultad en dar más gasto realizan
en su alimentación pues a marcela ya
oiga muchísimas gracias por este
análisis de la situación que se está
viviendo en ucrania al día de hoy les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
a ustedes también muchas gracias por la
sintonía sigan con france24
[Música]